personnel and debating chamber emerging
for question time one final time a first
Minister departing after 3 000 days at
the top I'm looking forward to my two
six and final session for some questions
thank you a leader leaving at a time of
Crisis for her own party the next item
of business is first ministers questions
a woman for one last political taunt
now the first Minister's farewell tour
this week has been a master class in
deceit and political spin she was too
busy far too busy to feed in front of
the Scott Affairs select committee but
somehow somehow managed to eat up Eco
time in her schedule to sit down and
lose women today marks the final
contribution after the sparring came
time for one last speech reflecting on
the longest Premiership in the highest
office words will never
adequately convey the Gratitude and the
all I hold in my heart
for the opportunity I have had to serve
as your first minister
it truly has been the privilege of my
lifetime and with these words presiding
officer I draw it to a close
thank you
Nicholas darjin will be reflecting on
failing to secure Scottish independence
but there is no doubt she ran a tight
ship a political machine and this
leadership contest that a Placer has
exposed cracks it's led to accusations
and resignations and it will leave her
successor to pick up the pieces
do you have regrets about how the
party's been like uh no I have great
confidence in the future of my party
even in the last few days when there's
been hyperbolic phrases used about
collapse and all sorts of things you
know you look at most opinion polls and
they still show the SNP way ahead of
anyone else her opponents argue she
leaves behind a legacy of issues a
Litany of problems or supporters say
sturgeon was a once in a generation
political operator Connor Gillis Sky
News Hollywood